Welcome.
Welcome back to our table as we open up the final pages of The Master and the Disciple and the really profound framework laid out by its author, Jafar ibn Mansur Ayaman.
Yeah, it's great to be back into this text.
This deep dive closes the dialogue.
The Disciple's 5 portion economy, the scholar's refusal, the trust held for the rightful master,
and a power whose cause has a name.
The purification portion is a trust for the rightful master until you meet him.
That is just, it's such a heavy place to start.
It really is.
I mean, we spend our entire lives acquiring resources, building our lives around what we can gather.
But today, we are closing this text with maybe the most terrifying question a seeker could possibly ask their teacher.
Like, how much of this is actually mine to keep?
And to understand how this completely upends our conventional concept of ownership, we first have to, well, anchor ourselves in the foundational teachings of the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family.
Because up until this point in the narrative, the disciple has been carried through this towering intellectual architecture.
Yeah, exploring the union of the inner and the outer divine justice.
Intricate dream interpretation, all of it.
But eventually all of that abstract doctrine has to hit the hard ground of daily reality.
And there is no reality more grounding than what is literally sitting in your pocket.
Exactly.
The narrative pivots from these lofty concepts to the most concrete situation imaginable.
The disciple looks at the scholar
and essentially asks for an audit.
He wants to know his actual physical obligations regarding his possessions.
So the scholar answers this by laying out a very clean, straightforward outer rule.
Yeah, he delivers it in these really distinct steps.
First, take only what was lawfully acquired.
Meaning you have to examine the supply chain of your wealth.
Precisely.
Ensure no one was exploited in the process of gaining it.
Second, pay the obligatory alms from the whole of it.
Okay.
Third, take a fifth from the finest portion.
Like the specific part of your wealth
you love the most.
Exactly that part.
Take 1/5 of that and spend it on those most deserving.
And finally, keep the remainder to spend on your family in your accustomed manner, giving any surplus to the needy.
It sounds like a basic ledger, but the scholar frames it as a literal physical purification.
He explains that you purify your possessions through charity in the exact same way you purify your physical body through virtuous acts.
The wealth itself requires A cleansing mechanism.
And that baseline is meticulously constructed from scripture.
We see this mapped out in the Quran, specifically in chapter 103 on repentance, which explicitly instructs that taking charity from wealth purifies it.
And causes it to increase.
Yes.
The scholar isn't inventing a new accounting method.
He is unfolding the reality that wealth, much like the physical body, accumulates A residue.
And A deliberate act of parting with it is the only mechanism that removes that residue.
Definitely.
And furthermore, verse 41 on the spoils of war establishes that the 5th belongs to the divine, to the messenger, and to specific categories like the near of kin and the needy.
Are we sure this isn't just making a simple charity rule overly complicated?
I mean, why not just give it all away?
If the ultimate goal of the seeker is detachment from the material world, why build this intricate mathematical structure to manage the money?
Because giving everything away blindly doesn't train the soul in the way it needs to be trained.
Really.
The structure is the pedagogy.
Emptying your pockets might make you poor, but it doesn't necessarily make you wise.
I see.
The scholar is taking a rule the disciple already knows in its outer form and forcing him to give it an inner form.
But here is where the narrative shifts.
The disciple's surprise.
Exactly.
The disciple surprises the scholar.
He hasn't just been passively listening.
He has essentially audited his own soul using his bank account.
Oh, that's fascinating.
And he reveals that he has already enacted an elaborate 5 portion spiritual economy of his own.
Let's examine what the disciple actually worked out, because it's a fascinating map of how a student learns to think organically rather than just repeating what he was told.
So portion one is exactly what the scholar asked for.
The standard obligatory purification, the basic alms.
But then the ledger becomes deeply psychological.
Portion 2 is set aside as an atonement for the harm he had done to his own soul before this dialogue even began.
And the brilliance of that second portion is its permanence.
He keeps it as a physical, tangible remembrance of his past sins.
Yeah, he explicitly states he does this to avoid complacency.
Think about how we usually handle guilt today.
We pay a parking ticket or make
quick reactionary donation, and we expect a clean conscience immediately.
We want the guilt to vanish the moment the money leaves our hands.
Exactly.
But the disciple refuses to let himself off the hook that easily.
By holding onto this atonement portion, the memory of his fallibility stays visible.
He refuses to buy a clear conscience too cheaply.
He uses the unspent money as a daily confrontation with his own flaws.
Then we have portion 3, which he calls the gratitude portion, thanking the divine for the knowledge he has acquired.
But rather than spending it immediately to feel virtuous.
Which is what most of us would do.
He intends to hold it as a trust, untouched, until he reaches spiritual maturity and truly knows where it should be spent.
That requires immense discipline.
It is incredibly tempting to dispense with charity immediately to get that emotional gratification.
That rush of feeling like a benefactor.
Yeah, to hold it in trust means delaying that emotional payoff.
It means forcing yourself to be patient until you possess the wisdom to be an effective person.
giver rather than an impulsive one.
Then we get to portion 4, the portion designated for the needy among his brothers, and he insists on giving this hand to hand.
No intermediaries.
None.
No anonymity, which completely inverts how we normally think about philanthropy today, where anonymity is considered the ultimate moral flex.
We assume anonymous giving is superior because it protects the ego of the giver and prevents them from showing off.
But the disciple realizes that anonymous giving also strips the receiver of a human connection.
By handing it over himself, the disciple deliberately absorbs the awkwardness of being seen as the giver, but in exchange he grants the receiver the ultimate dignity of a face.
They are acknowledged as a human being, not just a line item on a charity sheet.
And this perfectly mirrors the profound wisdom found in the brilliant aphorisms.
Remind me of that one.
It's where the father of imams is reported to have said that the worth of every person is what they do well.
Oh yes.
The disciple hasn't even read that aphorism yet, but his own internal reflection led him to the exact same conclusion about the vast difference between a faceless transaction and a gift given face to face.
That nuance is just extraordinary.
And then there is the 5th portion.
The smallest, most personal cut of his wealth.
He saved this specific
specifically to support the scholar in his travels.
He wants to care for the lordly teacher who carried him to the edge of understanding.
So when you look at the entirety of this framework, we can see a 5 portion economy as five separable kinds of inner work, not 5 equal sums.
The amounts themselves don't matter nearly as much as the internal mechanisms they trigger.
Purification of the visible, remembrance of sin, gratitude held in trust,
generosity that grants dignity and love for the teacher.
He is using his wealth as a direct mirror for his spiritual progression.
But the scholar's reaction to hearing this plan is incredibly intense.
He weeps.
And then he gives a layered refusal.
He completely refuses his own portion.
He tells the disciple, quote, I have fled the conflicts and temptations of wealth.
This is a profound moment of modeling the tradition.
There is a deeply ingrained prophetic teaching that the upper hand is better than the lower hand, which receives.
The truest scholars operate as a shield against the material world.
They take from the world only what is absolutely necessary to survive and pass the rest on.
By refusing the money, the scholar is proving his authenticity to the student.
I don't buy that yet.
Why redirect the portion the disciples set aside for the scholar himself?
Rejecting the money to show personal detachment is one thing, but completely re-architecting the student's heartfelt gift seems like an overstep.
Why not just let the student learn from the act of offering it?
Well, because the scholar's role isn't just to be a passive recipient of the disciple's affection.
His role is to align the disciple with the ultimate reality of the tradition.
And he doesn't reject everything.
He actually validates the psychological work the student has done.
He tells them, yes, give to your brothers hand to hand so they see you.
He confirms the internal audit.
Yes.
Keep the atonement portion as a remembrance of your sins.
Yes, hold the gratitude portion in trust until you mature.
But the purification portion.
The very first portion the disciple thought he had figured out how to dispense.
The scholar entirely redirects it.
He tells him it is not the disciples to give to ordinary recipients.
The purification portion is a trust for the rightful master until you meet him.
That pivot is the structural core of this entire text.
And naturally the disciple asks,
who this noble person is, who is the rightful judge for whom this portion is held?
And the scholar introduces the architecture of trust.
He speaks of the Imam.
He describes this figure not just as a leader,
but as the spiritual judge of the age.
He says this is the one whose right has been made obligatory upon every believer.
The one who holds the keys to the heavenly gardens.
The guide whose palms reveal the light of the mountain of Sinai.
Daftree's historical work on Ismaili traditions, the Ismailis, points out something crucial here regarding that architecture.
This isn't just a metaphor for a wise king.
No, it's much deeper.
The prophet established that he was leaving behind two profound sources of guidance.
The book of the divine as the outer form and his family as the living continuation of the inner truth.
The 2 weighty things.
Exactly.
So when the disciple thought he could dispense the purification portion based on his own personal judgment of who was needy, he was structurally mistaken.
That portion inherently belongs to the second of those two weighty things.
It must be held in trust for that living continuation of the inner truth.
It is an entire mechanism of trust that connects the physical coin in the disciple's hand directly to the highest spiritual authority on earth.
And this realization sets the final events of the narrative in motion.
The scholar departs.
He travels until he reaches his own spiritual father.
The elder master.
Yeah.
He narrates the disciple's story and the elder master recognizes the young man's immense qualities.
And he issues a very specific instruction.
Hurry back with this young man for I desire for him to become a gateway of loving kindness that may open for the people of his time.
We have to unpack that word gateway.
It's loaded.
Paul Walker explores this extensively in his work on early philosophical Shyism.
When the elder master says gateway, he is not just offering
a poetic compliment about the disciple having an open heart.
It is an institutional reality.
Yes.
When Walker describes this as a strict institutional office, he means the disciple is literally becoming the bottleneck.
He is the designated channel through whom spiritual instruction flows downward to the seekers.
And through whom their allegiance passes upward.
He's no longer just a student.
He is being promoted into the formal architecture of the tradition.
He is the active bridge for his generation.
But the physical toll of this promotion and the waiting involved is staggering.
The scholar hurries back just as instructed, but when the reunion happens, he finds the disciple radically transformed.
His body's weak.
His complexion is completely pale, and the source names the cause explicitly.
It is the consuming love a lover suffers in separation from the beloved.
That sounds like wordplay calling a body-changing, longing love instead of illness.
I mean, people get sick when their immune systems
fail or from sheer physical exhaustion, not because someone left town for a few weeks.
It feels like the text is romanticizing a physical fever to make a theological point.
It sounds like romanticizing a fever until you look at the tradition's deep grammar of separation.
Look at what happened to the scholar in chapter 2.
Remember his pallor?
Oh.
Oh, I concede the point.
When we look back at the earlier chapters, the scholar himself suffered from a deep physical pallor.
He was deteriorating physically.
But that was caused by his constant vigil over the next world.
Yes, the body breaking down under spiritual weight.
So this pallor in the disciple is the exact inverse.
Precisely.
It isn't caused by looking toward the next world.
It is caused by the sudden absence of the channel that connected him to it.
The scholar was his bridge to that reality, and when the bridge vanished, the physical
body collapsed under the weight of the isolation.
It is a psychosomatic reality where the soul has lost its tether.
Think of the body as a scribe writing the soul's grief on the face of the lover parted from the beloved.
The body as a scribe.
That deeply connects to how the great Persian poet opens the spiritual epic.
Oh, absolutely.
He uses the metaphor of the reed torn from the reed bed whose wail is intelligible only to one who has been parted from a source.
The flute only makes music because it was hollowed out and separated from
the earth it grew in.
And that resulting wail, that hollow, aching sound, is the pure longing for its origin.
The disciples' physical pallor is that exact same wail, just written into human biology.
The longing is the ultimate proof that the original union was real.
So the scholar sees this physical deterioration.
He reads the disciple state perfectly and he offers a deeply moving comfort.
He tells him Allah knew what was in your heart.
The divine witnessed the physical manifestation of that spiritual grief.
So the trial of waiting was shortened.
And a special loving mercy was placed in the heart of the elder master for him.
It's beautiful.
The scholar announces the culmination of everything they have worked toward.
Start preparing for your journey, he says, for I'm taking you to the doorstep of your ultimate goal.
And he frames this entire transition with that profound formula.
There is no power but through Allah.
It serves as the ultimate realization.
Throughout this dialogue, they've dismantled the disciples' understanding of the world, rebuilt his intellect, restructured his wealth, and stripped away his physical strength.
Only to replace all of it with the singular truth that every ounce of power flows from 1 unified source.
And upon hearing that he is finally going to the doorstep of the ultimate goal, the source notes that the disciple sighed so heavily with joy and awe that his spirit almost left his body.
We leave him there, breathing out, standing on the absolute precipice of the meeting he has spent this entire book preparing to bear.
The purification portion is a trust for the rightful master until you meet him.
Which piece of what we already hold are we treating as ours to dispense?
when it was always a trust for its rightful claimant and what would change if we began keeping it that way starting now.